today we take another look at some Irish
mythology and a figure that we have
mentioned in a previous video perhaps
the most recognizable and iconic form
Orion Warchief to ever take the throne
Bal or throughout Irish mythology Bala
was extremely feared and he went by
several names including Beryl the smiter
Baloo of the evil eye and Baloo of the
piercing eye the Celtic origin of his
name was thought to be Balor rose which
meant the deadly one the old Irish at
Bull meaning to die and ball in Welsh
meaning either death or plague as we can
see by all of these names regardless of
the language or culture Baloo is
described as not a particularly pleasant
individual to be around the most
striking part of battles appearance was
the eye located in the middle of his
forehead in some occasions he was shown
to have three eyes and others he
appeared more like a cyclops with one
large eye there are several stories that
attempt to explain how battles I came to
be when Bala was a boy he looked into a
potion bottle I was being brewed by the
Druids who served his father the potion
was so toxic that the fumes caused the
boy to go a huge poisonous eye another
variation of this story states that the
fumes only entered one of bellows eyes
and it's this sigh that will be known as
the evil eye when he was amongst his own
people Bala would keep his eye closed
which is why you may come across some
depictions of him covering an eye but in
battle Bala would unleash the power of
his eye upon anyone who stood against
him because of the properties of bellows
eye and his own destructive nature he
was often seen as a deity associated
with death and blight the eye of Bala
was said to cause destruction upon
anything that crossed its gaze how
exactly the I killed those who saw it
isn't really explained in detail but the
eye is quite often described as been
extremely poisonous with bamas eye being
closed amongst his fellow for mauryans
it said that it would take four men just
to pry the eye open a large portion of
the success that the firm Orient's
achieved is true to Bala's eye and
because of this he would rise quickly in
the ranks and become an extremely feared
war chief and eventually king he would
only have one child a daughter named
Aleen and when the jords prophesized
that he would eventually die at the hand
of his grandson he locked his daughter
away in a tower but ironically he would
be partly respond
support for his daughter meeting the man
of her dreams and having a child
embattled possessed the large amount of
cattle but when he came across the
marvelous cow of qiyan of the Tour de
Danone he decided that he would steal
this cow it was when keying came looking
for his cow that he came across a lien
and felt instantly in love and the two
would have a child named Liu upon
hearing of the child's birth Bala
ordered the child to be killed but Liu
was no ordinary child and managed to
survive growing up to become one of the
fiercest warriors of the two at the
denon it was during the second battle of
muy tora that Liu would encounter his
grandfather and attempt to fulfill his
prophecy when Bala eventually unleashed
his eye he began to wreak havoc amongst
the two at a Danone even killing their
King Nuada in the process when Liu
finally came across his grandfather it
said that he fired a spear or a sling
through his eye knocking Bala's I
through the back of his head and
destroying the four Mauryan army behind
them Bella will then be beheaded as Liu
in the turret adamance liberated their
victory over the four Mauryan army valor
is a fairly important figure in Irish
mythology he was the most feared of all
the Mauryan leaders and he gives us
somewhat of a mythical tyrant although
it was never his intention it's through
bellows bloodline that were given some
of the greatest heroes to feature in
Irish mythology if you enjoyed this
video and you have any stories or
thoughts about bail or and feel free to
share them with me in the comments below
but as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
[Music]
you